[Musica]
non è una novità che oggi abbiamo a
disposizione contenuti culturali e
tecnologici di ogni genere per la prima
volta forse ogni bisogno che abbiamo
possiamo andare a cercare su internet le
informazioni che ci servono e avere un
sacco di conoscenza portata di mano
io ad esempio non ho la minima idea di
come si prepara al sushi
però se oggi volesse cimentarmi a
preparare questo piatto poter cercare
delle video ricette potrei addirittura
acquistare gli ingredienti su uno dei
più comuni siti e provare a cimentarmi
nella preparazione appunto di questa
ricetta questi strumenti però non
bastano a fare di me sicuramente un
mestolo del sushi
tuttavia abbiamo oggi la possibilità di
progettare dei contenuti che siano
facilmente diffondibili attraverso la
rete e siano anche facilmente
replicabili da persone con un altro
background culturale dall'altra parte
del mondo
questo in parte avviene anche grazie
alla cultura dei maker chi sono i maker
sono delle persone che uniscono
tecnologia e artigianato per creare
delle soluzioni innovative a basso costo
e queste soluzioni costituiscono di suo
una vera e propria innovazione da strada
un esempio tra tanti ad esempio è la
stampante 3d reprap un progetto che è
nato per essere open source per tutti un
progetto nato per essere auto
costruibili queste due linee guida hanno
trasformato un singolo progetto
in meno di dieci anni in una numerosa
famiglia di progetti derivati qua non si
parla solo di condivisione delle
conoscenze o condivisione degli
strumenti ma anche di fornire a un
numero sempre crescente di persone di
esprimere la propria creatività
a volte commettendo degli errori altre
volte invece sviluppando delle soluzioni
un po ingegnoso un po particolare ai
propri problemi o le proprie necessità
tuttavia c'è una realtà in cui il mondo
del making in questi anni sta trovando
un terreno molto fertile per potersi
sviluppare e per poter fornire soluzioni
ed un mondo dove le persone creano delle
soluzioni auto costruiscono le proprie
risposte quotidianamente ed è un po il
mondo della disabilità perché molto
spesso capita che bisogna adattare
qualcosa a trovare una piccola soluzione
ingegnarsi a risolvere un problema e
questo magari capita tutti i giorni ci
sono nello specifico alcuni campi dove
un po più difficile andare a creare
soluzioni autonome come ad esempio il
mondo dello sport le carrozzine per lo
sport anno di requisiti tecnici molto
particolari e questo comporta anche
ovviamente che abbiano dei costi molto
particolari soprattutto elevati
il costo delle carrozzine comporta che
le persone abbiano difficoltà a potersi
permettere la pratica dello sport e
anche le associazioni sportive hanno
difficoltà a poter avere i fondi per
divulgare la pratica dello sport alle
persone
ecco che non c'è bisogna allora di
andare a progettare l'ennesima
carrozzina ma c'è bisogno di cambiare un
po l'approccio è per questo motivo è
nato twils tools è un progetto di una
carrozzina per lo sport auto costruibili
vuol dire che ognuno di voi oggi
potrebbe andare in un supermercato
negozi di fai da te o una ferramenta che
lo può trovare sotto casa e realizzare i
pezzi che gli servono per costruire
questa carrozzina con un budget di poche
decine di euro e delle ruote da
bicicletta voi potete creare uno
strumento che sicuramente non ha la
performance di una carrozzina sportiva
ma vi permette di avviarli alla pratica
dello sport
poi se fare sport vi piace da cosa nasce
cosa
questa qua è nata per lo sport ma questo
progetto si può modificare
ricordate il progetto della reprap da 1
a una numerose famiglie di progetti
derivati e per questo motivo questo qua
si può modificare si può trasformare può
diventare una carrozzina per molti usi
diversi
basta scaricare dal sito le istruzioni e
poi realizzarle o che non roma gli
strumenti da fai da te oppure con di
macchinari digitali perché ci sono anche
i disegni 3d e questi disegni li
possiamo costruire all'interno di un pub
lab il fab lab non cesso la torino e un
laboratorio di fabbricazione digitale è
un modello che fa parte di una grande
famiglia di elaboratori diffusi in tutto
il mondo ovunque voi siate
potete recarvi in uno di questi posti e
realizzare il vostro progetto o in
questo caso una carrozzina
questo perché ognuno di questi
laboratori a un linguaggio comune ha dei
valori comune a degli strumenti comuni
questa versatilità del progetto ha
portato alla carta questa carrozzina
twils su diversi campi da gioco fino
arrivare alle palestre del comitato
paralimpico questo permesso sicuramente
un enorme incrementazione della qualità
del prodotto un enorme sviluppo che
grazie a tutta la community di persone
che mi sta aiutando sta andando avanti e
sta crescendo questo progetto anche
ricevuto la targa giovani del compasso
d'oro si tratta di un premio di
importanza mondiale ma soprattutto e
credo sia ancora più importante credo
che sia il segno che il mondo
dell'industrial design sta percependo un
cambiamento del linguaggio e questo
cambiamento è concreto e che oggi questo
cambiamento viaggio attraverso la rete
permette a sempre più persone di poter
interpretare un modo diverso per vivere
la propria mobilità permette a sempre
più persone di poter accedere alla
pratica dello sport e alla gioia di
muoversi non ci sono più dei limiti
territoriali di spazio in ecuador in un
fab lab
teniamo di corsi dove insegnano le
persone a costruire a riparare le
proprie carrozzine oppure in india dove
un gruppo di maker adattato il progetto
alle risorse che poteva trovare
localmente e credo che questo sia un
segno che ovunque ci sia la voglia di
fare ed innovare possiamo trovare il
posto giusto
grazie
[Applauso]